syndromes that's not obvious but it is true and this basic property that the syndromes partition both the state space
in which the encodings live and all of the possible polyer in the space into equal siiz pieces is something that's
true in general for stabilizer codes which will soon Define precisely although it's mostly just an aside at
this point it's worth mentioning that poly operations that commute with both stabilizer generators or equivalently
poly operations that result in the syndrome plus1 +1 but are not themselves proportional to elements of the stabilizer turn out to behave just like
single Cubit poly operations on The Logical Cubit that we encoded for example xxx commutes with
both stabilizer generators but it's not proportional to any element of the stabilizer and indeed it's clear if you
think about this code for a moment that the effect that this operation has on an encoding is equivalent to an X gate on
the logical Cubit that was encoded and again this is something that generalizes to all stabilizer codes now it's time to Define stabilizer
codes in general and the way that it works is that we do something completely analogous to what we just discussed for
the three-bit repetition code except that we pick different stabilizer generators which all refer to as P1
through PR for the sake of this explanation these stabilizer generators must all be n Cubit poly operations
where n is the number of cubits used for the encoding and we can't just pick any old set of stabilizer generators they
have to satisfy a few basic conditions first the stabilizer generators Must ALL commute with one
another in the case of the three-bit repetition code we didn't bother to take note of this but it is straightforward to observe that ZZ identity and identity
ZZ do in fact commute because Z commutes with itself and everything commutes with the
identity for stabilizer codes with more complicated stabilizer generators on the other hand including codes where we have
both x's and Z's appearing in the stabilizer generators this is an important condition that needs to be
checked one way to think about the need for this condition is that we're going to be treating the stabilizer generators as obs observables and by requiring that
they all commute we're ensuring that the order in which we perform these measurements doesn't
matter second the stabilizer generators must form a so-called minimal generating set which means that if we removed any
one of them we'd get a smaller stabilizer and one way to express this mathematically is shown here on the
screen strictly speaking this condition isn't really essential to the way that a stabilizer code Works in an operational
sense and sometimes it does make sense to think about non-minimal generating sets as we'll see in the next lesson but
for the sake of analyzing stabilizer codes and explaining their properties we're going to assume that this condition is in
place basically this condition guarantees that each observable that we measure to obtain the syndrome is adding
information about possible errors as opposed to being redundant and giving results that could easily be inferred from the other stabilizer generators as
observables and finally it must be the case that at least one nonzero Vector is fixed by all
of the stabilizer generators and that turns out to be equivalent to demanding that -1 time the identity on N cubits is
not contained in the stabilizer that's not obvious but the point is that it is possible to choose a minimal generating
set of n Cubit poly operations that all commute with one another and yet no Vector is simultaneously a plus one igen
vector of all of them and we don't want to concern ourselves with this possibility because codes where there aren't any valid encodings aren't
interesting so those are the requirements on the stabilizer generators for a stabilizer code and if we do have a set of generators that
satisfy these conditions then we have a valid stabilizer code and we can consider its properties there are many
different stabilizer codes with various properties that make them interesting or not but they all satisfy certain basic
properties that are reminiscent of the ones that we've already observed for the three-bit repetition code
we'll take a look at some examples shortly but before that let me mention that when we refer to the code space of a stabilizer code we mean the Subspace
of the N Cubit State space that includes every Vector that's simultaneously a plus one igen vector of every one of the
stabilizer generators this is the Subspace of the en Cubit State space in which valid encodings live and we'll have more to
say about this Subspace as the lesson continues now let's take a look at a few examples of stabiliz
codes here's the example we've already discussed the ordinary 3-bit repetition code and we can also Express the
modified version of that code from the previous lesson which can detect a phase flip instead of a bit flip as a stabilizer code AS is shown
here this time the stabilizer generators measure XX observables rather than ZZ observables so these are basically
parity checks in the plus minus basis rather than the standard basis in both cases we can can
immediately see that we have a valid stabilizer code because the stabilizer generators commute these are minimal
generating sets and the code space is non-trivial as we already know but we can also see pretty clearly that we
can't generate negative -1 time the identity and here's the 9 Cubit Shore code which is also a stabilizer code
expressed by stabilizer generators in this case we basically have three copies of the three- bit
repetition code one for each of the three blocks of three cubits as well as the last two stabilizer generators which
take a form that's reminiscent of the circuit that we saw in the previous lesson for detecting phase flips for this
code another way of thinking about these last two stabilizer generators is that they take exactly the same form as we
have for the three-bit repetition code for phase flips except that we substitute XXX for x and the reason for
that is that XXX corresponds to an X operation on The Logical Cubit encoded using the 3-bit repetition code but
that's an aside and it's not something to worry about right now in case it isn't clear next we'll take a look at a few
more examples but before that let me mention that people often omit the tensor product symbols when describing stabilizer codes because it tends to
make them easier to read so here's what these codes look like without the tensor product symbols
but of course these are tensor products and not ordinary Matrix products for instance we're just leading out the tensor product symbols so that it's less
cluttered and the patterns are more clear here's another example it's called
the 7 Cubit steam code and it has some pretty remarkable features we'll come back to this one
from time to time throughout the remaining lessons of the unit but for now we can simply verify that it is a valid stabilizer
code in particular the first three stabilizer generators clearly commute with one another because Z commutes with